hi everyone I'm Claire I'm a tasty
producer and today I'm going to show you
some back-to-school recipes that you can
make for your meal prepping is something
that I like to do on a weekly basis it
helps me stay organized and makes me
feel like I have a little bit of my life
together
I found that I actually eat so much
healthier when I plan out for the whole
week so transitioning that same concept
into meals for children is such a great
idea and as a parent it saves time one
of the easier ways to plan meal prepping
for kids is to pick a base vegetable
base protein and a base fruit to put in
every lunch you can mix it up day to day
by having one or two choices so in this
video what my coworker Hannah did was
she picked a couple of base vegetables
and a couple base fruits to play with so
that way she can add one or the other in
for a little variation and to keep lunch
interesting when I first started making
lunches for my niece and my nephew the
video I turned to was this one it's
really fun to give kids variety with
their lunches I think that making lunch
in activity helps with that and having
like build your own kind of dishes makes
it really exciting to eat and lets them
be a little creative with their lunch I
know how difficult it is to make a
different lunch every day and when that
lunch box comes home and all of that
food is just still in there it rides me
nuts so I try to make things as exciting
as I possibly can I'm all about
convenience and just to make it even
more convenient you can utilize the same
ingredients in different forms so that
way you're not having to spend extra
money buying extra ingredients to make
four days worth of food you could just
buy one package of tortillas and make
three different things out of it I think
packing lunches is important because
it's one way that I can show my niece
and nephew that I care about them and I
ask for their feedback all the time did
you like this did you like that like can
I put this in your lunch tomorrow too
and if I get an excited yes I know I've
done a good job by no means do you have
to follow exactly what is in the video
to a tee you can customize it to make
whatever you think your child would like
obviously not every kid is gonna like
hard-boiled eggs in their lunch but
that's okay you can put in something
else that you do know that they like
that way you can provide them with a
lunch that you know they're gonna enjoy
but it's also going to give them
sustainable energy throughout the rest
of the day another way you can meal prep
is by using leftover chicken or you can
buy one chicken shred it up and make
your lunches from there
chicken is one of the most popular meats
in the world and just about every kid I
know will eat chicken there's a variety
of recipes that you can make with
chicken which is why it's perfect for
meal prepping for kids lunches like I
said before you can use these as
jumping-off points if your kid doesn't
like chicken salad
you can make your own version or mix it
up with your favorite family recipe this
is just another way to optimize your
efficiency in the mornings you just have
one solid protein and you expand on it
from there and you can really go
anywhere with it just make sure to
remove all the bones and cartilage and
shred the chicken really well growing up
in my house I hated eating leftovers so
my mom would get sneaky and she would
turn the leftovers into something new so
I wouldn't even know that I was eating
leftovers for lunch so that was
something that really inspired me to
make this video and to pay homage to my
childhood as well as my upbringing
if it wasn't leftover as my lunches were
typically pretty boring and the same
every day so I didn't want the same for
my niece and nephew and that's why I put
in a lot of effort to make their food
exciting and fun to eat my niece is only
six so having a full day at school is a
really long time for her to go without
having a snack every five minutes I
really like making sure that she has
healthy choices for her lunch every day
making a lunch that she brings home with
a box totally empty is such a satisfying
feeling when you're that age lunch is
such an exciting time of the day and
it's even an exciting time of the day
for me as a 25 year old boy one of my
favorite things to do that my mom used
to do for me is to leave notes in their
lunches with funny little sayings and I
absolutely think that I'm the funniest
aunt in the whole entire world
because I leave the cheesiest corniest
notes and I crack myself up as I'm
writing them every morning I like to add
puns on little notes in their lunches
and I think I'm funny but I don't know
if anyone else does but like come on I
believe in you come on like let us taco
about it you being a good kid today I'm
funny give me the credit I'm funny for
my nephew since he's only three he can't
really read but my niece is starting to
be able to read and she either gets my
jokes or kind of looks at me in
disappointment like Oh auntie that was a
bad one I always thought it was so
special when my mom would put notes in
my lunch because it was just a little
reminder from her to me that she loves
me and cares about me so I'm carrying on
that tradition with my niece and nephew
[Music]
these cereal bars are the best snack for
anytime you can grab them and go for the
morning you can put them in a lunch you
can have them as an after-school snack
they really are the perfect food for any
time of day when you're making these
it's a perfect opportunity to involve
your child in the cooking process with
you it's the best when you see how proud
they are of themselves and you see a big
smile across their face my coworker
Hannah's son Jackson helped me make this
and he's usually my sous chef and tasty
Junior videos this particular day he was
really upset that we were putting the
yogurt chips in the mix I had to tell
him they're part of the recipe and we
have to put them in but you know what we
can do he could make a batch separately
just for you that doesn't have yogurt
chips in it and he really enjoyed having
his own little versions at the time I
was a little frustrated with him because
he was changing my vision but he really
taught me a valuable lesson in that you
should always customize your recipes to
your own preference another reason these
are great is because you can wrap them
up and save them in your fridge for
about three months before you'll need to
toss them these are just another way for
you to save time and also this way you
know what ingredients are going in
compared to the mystery ingredient
sugar-filled bars that there are out
there today
now with this snack I can't tell you
exactly what they're based on but it
starts with cheese
and it's a great snack but we'll just
call them baked cheese crackers for now
my favorite part about this recipe is
that it's four ingredients it really
doesn't take that long to make just a
little bit of effort but the effort is
worth it
these are something that I make for
myself all the time and they pair really
well a Chardonnay by the way they're
lighter and they have a really
satisfying crunch to them have the kids
help you cut out the shapes and put them
on a baking sheet and poke a hole in the
middle when you use the cookie cutters
it just makes it so much more fun and so
much more kid like you can add these
into lunches you can keep them for an
at-home snack you can hide them in the
back of the pantry for yourself whatever
you do just make them you can even play
with the type of cheese that you put in
them you can do mozzarella Colby jack
American no don't do American mozzarella
Colby jack pepper Jack if you're a
little fancy or you can even amp up the
flavor with a really great sharp cheddar
and you'll have really flavorful and
delicious cracker you can also use a
cookie cutter and just keep rolling out
the dough until you don't have any dough
left just like last time I told you guys
that they do read the comments and
believe me I know you can buy these in a
box but making them is so much better
and you can make the cutest little
shapes and they taste ten times better
promise go make them I mean it's only
four ingredients you probably have in
your house right now another surefire
way of making sure you know what your
kids are eating and what's going into
those foods
[Music]
this is another four ingredient really
easy snack
you could even really do it with three
ingredients you're really just
dehydrating the fruit and that's what's
taking so long but the end result is
worth it your to compare these two rolls
that you would buy at the store you can
look and see that there's far less
processed ingredients these are
something that you can do in big batches
you can do two or three sheet pans at a
time since they do take so long to bake
these are really really fun to eat and
so long the same lines of using little
to no added sugar just peel right off of
the parchment paper that they're on and
I would even eat them as a snack for
myself
because they're just that delicious the
last school year was a really
interesting learning process for me I
had to relearn what kids liked in their
lunches my now six-year-old niece and
three-year-old nephew landed in my life
just like a bomb I don't have the
typical aunt niece nephew relationship
my mom and I are their caregivers and
it's been a really big learning
experience for me to make them lunches
and play this role for them that was so
different from anything I'd ever done in
my life before that it's really taken a
lot of self-reflection and looking back
on my childhood in my life to help me
learn what to feed them and it's a lot
of testing asking for their feedback but
they always have so much gratitude for
the food that we make them and I'm so
lucky to have such wonderful kids to
feed before they came into our care I
was barely making lunch for myself let
alone eating something other than Pizza
rolls from the freezer so it's been a
big opportunity for me to explore some
of my favorite dishes from when I was a
kid and bring them back to share with my
niece and nephew school's already hard
enough and kids really look forward to
their lunch breaks I know I can't be
there all the time while they're at
school and I'm at work but knowing that
I've provided them with food that I know
they're gonna love it just makes it all
worth it that was it
oh yes
[Music]
[Music]